but you kind of contradicted yourself  because you said age is irrelevant but  then you said you wouldn't go under 25.  like like what's wrong with the 24 year  old that's got his stuff together okay  yeah I said 25 but yeah if it's a 24  year old but I'm not gonna go I'm not  gonna go really low because that's not  relevant for me and I know I'm not  saying how old I am but yes I understand  I apologize for if you felt a  contradiction myself but yeah there  there is a limit but an upper limit you  could be missing out on a great man or a  great woman I agree would you do the guy  that was 90.  it could be 110 treats me well just  wants to take me out to dinner and have  some company buy me nice things but you  still have to be respectful